На переїзд нас надихнула подорож.
Це була подорож з табуретом
до Північно-льодовитого океану.
Стало зрозуміло, що в Києві після такої краси і
після такого часу на природі, дуже важко лишатися.
Ідея була в тому,
щоб поселитися не самим, а одразу з друзями.
Тому ми шукали місце,
де є не одна якась пуста хата в селі,
а щоб їх було декілька.
Я просто подивилася на цей краєвид,
на ці сосни поруч —
і так ми вирішили залишитися тут.
Хотілося безпечного місця для нас і для дітей.
Хотілось місця, яке естетично
та екологічно – не агресивне.
Ми насамперед виставили
собі критерії, за якими шукатимемо.
Перший – віддаленість від Києва
в певному радіусі. Потім – хороші дороги.
І один з найважливіших факторів,
який у нас був при пошуку, –
це наявність або хоча б зачатки спільноти.
Ще один з критеріїв – наближеність
до водойми, де можна рибалити.
[сміється]
Обов'язково.
Про Обирок я чула насправді давно.
І для мене це було щось із паралельного простору.
«Як це взагалі можливо?»
Є якийсь такий мистецький хутір!
Ну це ж мистецький хутір,
це не просто дім чи село. Це егегей!
[англійською] Лише сам факт, що я з Аргентини,
є досить дивним для людей у цих широтах.
[англійською] «Чому? Що ти тут робиш?»
Це викликає в них щирий подив.
[англійською] Я кочовий митець,
який мандрує світом, створюючи дерев’яні скульптури.
[англійською] Я побачив сторінку на фейсбук та зацікавився.
[англійською] Тож зв’язався із Діаною —
однією із засновниць цього місця.
[англійською] І вона мені відповіла:
«Звісно ж, будемо вам раді, приїжджайте,
[англійською] ми знайдемо місце,
де вас розмістити.
[англійською] Ви зможете створювати
свої скульптури без перешкод».
[англійською] Тож я так і зробив.
Обирок складається із трьох хуторів:
Каціри, Прохори і Королі.
На кожному хуторі приблизно десять хатин.
Тобто ми їх усі об'єднали в хутір Обирок.
Обирок — це назва, якою місцеві,
із сусідніх сіл люди, називають цей куточок.
Зараз тут три хати місцевих.
Все решта – або обиряни,
які приїхали на концепцію цього хутора.
А також є кілька будиночків, так звані дачники.
Ми одразу започаткували це місце
як місце для заходів і місце для творчого прояву.
Де буде зніматись кіно,
де будуть якісь фестивалі.
І взагалі, різноманітні активності
пов'язані з мистецтвом.
Ми були тоді єдиною сім'єю з дитиною,
і я зрозуміла, що дуже не вистачає ще дітей.
Тоді я почала організовувати табори.
У нас виник проєкт «Діти природи».
Це щорічний табір, який відбувався
вісім років поспіль.
І паралельно я почала робити
тут домашню школу для дітей.
«Кіносарай» — це був колишній сінник.
І перша думка, яка виникла: «О, клас.
Якщо тут повісити екран, це може бути кінотеатр»
Ми почали робити фестиваль,
який так і назвали «Кіносарай».
Тобто в нас виник свій
повноцінний кінофестиваль на Обирку.
Ми вирішили робити невеликий тестовий режим
для тих, хто хоче поселитися в Обирку.
Він складається з трьох кроків.
Перший – з усіма перезнайомитись.
Друге – пожити тут місяць або два,
бажано в холодний період.
Щоб відчути, як це — коли немає заходів,
немає гостей, немає фестивалів.
І відчути таке спокійне життя
маленького хутору.
І третє – це зробити якийсь проєкт
разом з кимось з обирян.
Щоб відчути цю взаємодію
і наскільки взагалі у нас «є контакт».
На Обирку від початку така енергія активності,
дії, створення чогось із нічого.
І власне, воно так і лишається.
Дуже часто хтось готовий зробити щось
просто тому, що є на це воля і енергія.
Такі люди звуться волонтери, і мені,
з моєї сторони, хочеться подбати про них.
Щоб їм було сухо тепло і щоб вони мали місце,
де можуть переночувати, поїсти.
Тому ми вирішили створити «Спільнохату»
як простір для обирського мобільного ком'юніті.
Коли люди можуть приїхати, пожити
деякий час, поїхати, знову повернутись.
Тобто це такий будиночок,
де постійно міняються мешканці.
Обирянин – людина, яка вважає це
місце своїм і піклується про нього.
— Неважливо, де вона живе, хоч в Австралії...
— Це людина, яка вносить сюди енергію.
...хоч в Аргентині — де завгодно.
Якщо вона за це переживає, за це піклується,
вносить свою енергію – вона обирянин!
І ось ця спільність обирян,
для них потрібна спільна хата – «Спільнохата».
Приблизно років 10 тому ми почали дуже активно
працювати з міжнародними волонтерами.
Колись порахували, що Обирок відвідали
люди приблизно з 40 країн.
І зазвичай у нас збиралися влітку, в теплий сезон.
Але от у нас уже є прецедент
з французом Бенджаміном,
який приїздив сюди як волонтер,
а потім оселився тут.
Тому можемо назвати Обирок першим міжнародним
ком'юніті чи екопоселенням в Україні.
В нас уже є один француз,
тепер ще Фабіан з'явився.
Не знаю, чи він тут залишиться на постійно,
але принаймні регулярно приїжджає.
Проводить тут по декілька місяців на рік тепер.
[англійською] Коли я бачу щось,
що інші вважають за непотріб, якийсь мотлох,
[англійською] я завжди намагаюсь зануритися
трішки глибше у це перше враження,
[англійською] та подивитись,
чи можу я угледіти якусь красу в цьому.
[англійською] І я відкрив для себе,
що немає значення, яке воно на вигляд ззовні.
[англійською] Я впевнений,
що там є прихована краса.
[англійською] І я маю допомогти
їй проявити себе.
[англійською] Мої скульптури не мають нічого
спільного з якоюсь інтелектуальною ідеєю,
[англійською] або з проєктом,
який я б спочатку намалював,
[англійською] а потім втілював у шматку деревини. Ні.
[англійською] Певною мірою я відчуваю,
[англійською] що я більше інтерпретатор,
ніж митець.
[англійською] Бо справжній митець – то природа.
[англійською] Є намір продемонструвати людям,
[англійською] що можливо створити якусь красу з речей,
які спершу не здаються красивими.
[англійською] Та що будь-хто з нас може це робити.
У нас країна і суспільство за останнє століття
пережило дуже, дуже багато важких процесів.
Війни, голодомори, геноциди, розстріли...
І біль цього всього не проговорений,
не випущений, не відтерапевтований.
Тобто він проявляється у різні способи.
Спілкуючись з місцевими, більшість
з яких тут народилися, як і їхній весь рід...
І вони, власне, тут переживали величезну
кількість болю і трагедій, які нікуди не поділися,
які проявляються в їхніх дітях
і, намагаючись з ними взаємодіяти.
Намагаючись реалізовувати якісь проєкти,
які не обмежуються Обирком і обирянами.
І ось можливість бути дотичним до власне джерела болю,
дає багато простору, щоб його проживати.
Для того щоб знаходити його в собі,
знаходити його в своєму роді і розуміти:
[російською] Що ви всі не «такі», а ми всі «такі».
А в тонших якихось світах це вирішувати.
Коли довго живеш і займаєшся тільки своїм місцем,
здається, що ти один взагалі
на планеті такий –
дивна людина, яка намагається
альтернативне життя будувати.
Коли всі заробляють гроші і будують кар’єру в містах...
Таких диваків насправді досить багато,
і їх багато по світу.
Тобто є організація
«Global Ecovillage Network» (GEN).
Є окремі напрями: азійське об’єднання,
європейське, американське.
І є світова організація,
де такі активні екопоселенці
з’їжджаються на ці з’їзди,
обмінюються знаннями, досвідом.
Ми почали їздити в інші
поселення по Україні. Знайомитись.
Кликати всіх в цю організацію.
Організували минулого
і цього року два з’їзди екопоселень.
Тут, в Обирку, це відбувалося.
І зараз у нашій мережі
близько п’ятнадцяти екопоселень.
І ще кілька індивідуальних
таких господарств дауншифтерів.
Чи людей, які переїхали в село
або займаються екопроєктами.
[англійською] Досвід Обирку підштовхує людей
почати задуматись над тим,
[англійською] що світ має також інші можливості.
[англійською] Я не кажу, що те,
як в Обирку все облаштовано та працює,
[англійською] це, мовляв, єдиний правильний шлях,
або що всі мають робити це так, як в Обирку. Ні.
[англійською] Кожен повинен знайти свій шлях
у житті та робити те, чого йому хочеться.
[англійською] Але я вважаю, що багато хто знаходить
своє життєве натхнення тут, у цьому місці.
Обирок – для багатьох простір свободи.
Це місце, де можна бути собою
і просто проявлятись як тобі хочеться.
Обирок – це місце зустрічей
і простір довіри й безпеки.
Тобто люди відчувають себе
безпечно одне з одним.
Є ком’юніті людей, які тут живуть.
І є ще досить велике ком’юніті, яке тут не живе.
Але регулярно приїжджають, ми колись
підраховували, що приблизно сотні людей.
Сидячи тут, здавалося б,
за сотні кілометрів від цивілізації.
Уже в перший рік я зрозуміла,
що соціальне життя в мене тут
набагато насиченіше,
ніж всередині міста.
Особливо маючи маленьких дітей.
Щодня хтось зупиняється біля клубу
на машині, виходить і питає:
«У вас десь тут має бути хутір Обирок,
якесь там цікаве місце».
І мені щоразу хочеться сказати,
що Обирок – це не кілька хат.
Це не артоб’єкти чи щось «от таке незрозуміле мистецьке».
Обирок – це люди.
Насамперед і найголовніше: Обирок – це люди.
І люди тут дуже класні, круті.
Цього літа я виїхала на велику,
в мене було кілька справ,
які треба було вирішити із сусідами.
І я себе піймала на тому, що зі всіма, хто кого зустріла,
мені було дуже приємно поспілкуватися.
Було дуже радісно їх зустріти.
Я просто отримувала насолоду від того,
що ці люди зараз тут.
Тому головний фактор для мене на Обирку – це люди.
І ті люди, які приїжджають на заходи так само.
Ти починаєш з ними говорити,
знайомитись і вони класні.
Ти відчуваєш, що ти з ними на одній хвилі.
Ви одне спільне плем’я, хоч,
можливо, живете в різних місцях.
[англійською] Що мені тут подобається, що я бачу,
[англійською] це місце з тотальною відкритістю
до нових ідей та величезною свободою.
[англійською] Ти просто мусиш бути собою.
[англійською] І все якось відбувається природно.
[англійською] Є за всім цим організація,
але для мене ще й досі загадка,
[англійською] як це місце взагалі працює,
але воно працює.